[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
dexter new blood episode 3
smoke signals this was written by david
mcmillan and directed by sanford
bookstaver so this episode was
interesting to me where i really praised
the first two episodes
this one's a little more
where i would have envisioned before
this season where i get worried about it
feeling a little stale a little
repetitive from the old dexter and when
i was complimenting the first two and
feeling how fresh they were this one
took a step back in that department for
me and i was also complimenting the
first two episodes that they were going
away from doing the side stories and
dexter in the past that could be you
know a lot of eye rolling going on while
you watch it a little sappy a little
drawn out a little corny and you get a
little bit of that here which was a
little frustrating because we haven't
really seen that yet in this season and
really where that highlights is where i
always say i'm worried about if you
familiar with my reviews is that when
you bring in a teenage character you got
to be careful because with that becomes
some you know story lines that get
frustrating to watch it's just common
knowledge that people
aren't crazy about storylines this like
having the bullies at the high school
these goofy teens that are catfishing
this poor kid so it kind of leaned a lot
into that or maybe if they put a little
less into it i would have been more
satisfied but you know this episode
really was cut in half between
harrison's story and dexter's story and
where there's some silly moments here we
could even start in harrison's story
where they first called dexter to the
school talk the principal and the
principal's like where were you dexter
when he harrison was at foster school
and the principal and the vision becomes
deborah in the same outfit as the
principal which came off just silly to
me you know at that point just have
deborah appear behind the principle to
do that moment not dress her up in the
same outfit i thought that was goofy but
we see actually a lot of similarities in
this episode in harrison's story to
dexter that harrison sees someone
getting hurt wants to protect them i
always compare the story of dexter to
superhero stories in particular i've
compared it in the past to like
daredevil or the punisher and the
punisher is what we kind of get alluded
to here because this character of ethan
that he defends has these drawings that
are really messed up which was
interesting because harrison smiled at
these so you're like oh wait maybe
harrison does have a lot like his father
and ethan bring up the punisher so we
see these moments where harrison goes
with that theme of justice but in a
violent way by holding zach by his neck
in the hallway defending the innocent
just like dexter wants to and that in
their violent actions are doing it for a
just cause so harrison does have that
similarity with dexter but it's going to
see how much how different it is but
that worked and i get that for the
purpose of developing harrison's
character more as we get to know him and
how he handles situations very similar
to dexter it doesn't mean though that
it's that entertaining or satisfying
watching it and you know we got a lot of
harrison here with audrey again in this
car and then they want to take a proper
ritual for this white buck this is where
you can get into where it reminds me of
the dexter the old where it gets a
little sappy you know it's all to set up
dexter really seeing that fire from the
white buck to get the idea to burn the
body of mats so that storyline was a
little drawn out to me there is some
interesting stuff though when audrey's
car breaks down this billionaire mr
olsen is very weird to her pushing her
to come with him it's going to add to
the theories of mr olsen also being in
that betting pool of who this mysterious
killer is of this girl where i had said
it's probably clancy brown i'm still
sticking by that the actor clancy brown
aka kurt caldwell but it might also be
mr olsen they both have blue eyes and if
they're only showing little bits of mr
olsen at this point the billionaire you
know there's something up there so yeah
he's definitely someone to consider on
that list of who this killer could be
and speaking of that killer we see that
he didn't kill the girl yet where i
thought maybe they would open with the
dead body here but we actually see he
has his mo showing to us now that he
lets her loose like she's gonna go free
and then hunts her and shoots her down
you know like something from game of
thrones when in battle the bastards are
running away it felt kind of like that
it was cool it was a cool shot too the
drone shot above her when she's running
away and the music worked and we get
more info that he takes his victims and
he draws blood from them into a bucket
so it's nice that they're giving us
breadcrumbs about our mysterious color
which always works and not giving away
the full story here which i like what i
also enjoyed positive this episode is
everything going on with the cop logan
here right from the beginning of the
episode he's already like very into
getting harrison on the wrestling team
but i also feel there's a sense of he
was already kind of eyeing dexter here
and that he wants to be close to
harrison because that will also get him
closer to dexter and get into what is up
with this guy dexter because he's on his
radar and we clearly see that when he
interviews dexter and that was my
favorite scene in the episode very tense
and that's the suspense where dexter's
at its best when he's showing the
footage of dexter to dexter on the heat
vision here so it's not clear but he's
really got an eye on dexter because
dexter does not look good here the way
he's talking about it and constantly
saying like can i go so not only is
dexter rusty about how he's handling his
murder scenes but he's rusty about how
he lies too we learned though that there
was this camera that's placed in the
woods near the crime scene and they do
that for the animal tracking i thought
that led to a very suspenseful scene in
the beginning when they're first showing
the footage and dexter's in there with
the cops but i would have liked when
dexter was first getting them off his
scent and where the body actually is of
mats that he took matt's jacket hunting
jacket and used that dna to get the dogs
that way but you see dexter stepping
around the crime scene where we know now
that there's cameras so i do wish in
that moment though in that exact scene
when he's dragging the jacket that we
got to see him you know acknowledge the
camera again and make sure how is he
doing this without them seeing him doing
this you know so that kind of didn't add
up to me enough i think they had to
clarify that even though they did see
him look at the camera when they were at
the crime scene later on they should
have shown it when he was actually
covering himself and how he got away
with that where he could do it stealthy
without getting caught also nice small
detail as angela mentions to kurt she
does plan on having a search team go to
the caves to look for matt and that's a
big point and it gets a nice payoff
because that was dexter's original place
to put the bodies in the caves because
that's where deborah suggested in his
vision and he doesn't end up because he
sees this bear he runs away out of the
cave i think it's a bear in the screener
copy it's like an animated computer bear
so i wonder if they stick with it a bear
so let me know in the comments i'm
curious about that but anyway he runs
away so then it doesn't end up going in
the caves the body that was his plan so
that actually worked out in his favor
because if he did do that he probably
would have got caught so we also see
this is becoming a popular type of
character in shows like dexter where we
meet jamie chung's character of molly
park uh she's a great actress jamie
chung and she's playing this true crime
podcaster so like i said yeah you'll see
this in shows now because it is
something that really comes with the
territory now when you have a big case
in real life you're going to get someone
wanting to cover at a journalist a
podcaster so it makes sense that shows
are doing this now and adding that
character just like you would a reporter
or you know an investigator but she's
going to be interesting because she's
going to be someone that has all this
big following and we'll probably be like
a logan type character that is on to
dexter at some point what also adds to
the theories by the way there's little
hints that it might be you know kirk
caldwell as the killer here of this girl
is that when they asked for his dna he
hesitated to give his dna and that could
be no killer would want the cops just to
have a recent swab of their dna it's
just not something you do i thought that
was interesting we also get some
information confirmed here that iris who
they keep talking about with angela's
past you know clearly someone close to
her in her life that went missing yeah i
said it could be the sister or maybe her
past daughter and it's confirmed it is
her former sister so that's important
for angela's character but you know
whoever did take her sister could be the
same killer that we're seeing so
learning about her story might lead to
learning about who the carolers in this
current story what's big about character
moans for dexter here is that he is
starting to listen to deborah again in
the sense of that he's like okay i'm i'm
going back to abstinence here when he
burns the body but he's still reflective
though saying things like what if it's
the not killing that got me in trouble
so he does always question you know is
it worth it even this abstinence in the
same episode which i like because it
goes back and forth in his head but he
is here more leaning towards the deborah
side of things getting back to focusing
on having a relationship with harrison
and not killing and there's good moments
here when they have the family he calls
it a family dinner basically he's like
wow i didn't think i'd have a family out
here where he was going to be secluded
in the woods but he's with audrey
harrison and angela at the table and you
know that's when he gets interrupted
thinking about moving the body but he's
actually got to move this white buck
when he really wants to move the body
that night which i thought worked so
well how they even edited that whole
scene at the dinner table but it gets
that payoff where you know dex sees how
close the reservation group is during
their ritual and he wants to get that
close with harrison he's made that clear
he apologized to harrison about
everything that went on school with the
principal and harrison finally calls him
dad and he he loves it so that's
something that's kind of keeping him
like i said which i like that they have
harrison kind of take that reader role
in some sense of keeping him grounded
keeping him from going into that monster
dexter that he's always tempted the dark
passenger so the big final moment here
is he sees kirk caldwell just super
drunk and he's like that doesn't look
like someone who's grieving
and they're standing under matt's ashes
which is just crazy because he just
burnt the body and kurt has no idea but
the twist is that kurt makes up to him
that matt's alive and that he's facetime
him and talk to him so he's like why
would he lie so that's obviously a big
curve here as well so please give your
theories on why would he lie why is kurt
saying this to dexter at this given
moment i'd love to hear you guys
thoughts on that but yeah i think you
know there's some good moments i mean
like i said i can watch deborah and
dexter together all day i love when
she's suggesting ways to get rid of the
body and she's grinding it and he's like
you know that seems a little too uh
fargo i thought that was great you know
they're they're on screen chemistry
always off the charts so that that
continues here but this episode to me as
a whole you know you felt where shows
get frustrating and when they start
stretching things for the first time to
me because then you split the story into
harrison's school story dexter's story
and like i said about a lot of seasons
the dexter frustrated me he's like yeah
the dexter stuff's really interesting
and this was a time where we got us a b
plot that's okay you know the harrison
stuff the white buck stuff it's okay you
know it's it's not memorable i don't
think this episode is gonna be one we
talk about as we go on it's just kind of
keeping the story going along where
episode one was really good at
introducing us to where dexter's at
episode two really set well the story of
the season but this one i thought you
know i would have appreciated a little
more interesting things or reveals
happening here and moving the plot a
little quicker and not so much high
school stuff but maybe that's my
preference and bias about you know
stories with like angsty teens but
overall i'm giving this one a 7.8 that's
just how i feel about watching it you
know it's brought down quality bit and i
made the concern in the beginning of
this review that this was the one that
felt a little too similar to dexter of
old and that goes to having you know the
side plot that's not as interesting and
a little sappy but also it's going
towards okay this still is like i don't
want to get into his owners like this is
just dexter we've seen before where he's
just lying to people and hiding a
killing you know like i wanted to be
more fresh it's just seems like it's a
continuation at this episode this is the
one that felt the most to me like okay
this just seems like the dexter we know
but you don't want it to be too similar
because then you might start questioning
in your head like is this show even
necessary so i think we just want to
keep fresh stuff happening i think that
will come and i still have high hopes
for this season i think they're still
setting up some really interesting stuff
in particular too as we learn more and
more about what harrison's really like
so let me know you thought down below if
you agree with my rating if you thought
it was really good i'd love to hear all
your thoughts your theories please as
well uh please follow me at steve varley
show on twitter instagram and tick tock
so you don't miss any of my reviews i
got interview clips in there as well you
can check out my interviews on my
channel if you really love what i do
here i really appreciate if you could
just donate and become a member it helps
me in so many ways you have no idea i
could do this full time review more
shows and movies for you guys and you'll
get special perks as well and i'll see
you next week